bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo toute l'actualité politique résumé
en 45 minutes et dans l'actualité cette
semaine cela commence par une bonne
nouvelle la libération des otages
retenus en afghanistan les deux
journalistes hervé ghesquière et
stéphane taponier ont rejoint le sol
français ce jeudi matin il était détenu
depuis 547 jours martine aubry
officiellement candidate aux primaires
du parti socialiste une annonce qui
tombe le jour de l'ouverture des
candidatures elle n'a pas perdu de temps
et déjà les critiques pleuvent du côté
de l'ump on y reviendra
christine lagarde nommée à la tête du
fmi l'heure était donc au remaniement du
gouvernement françois baroin a reporté
le duel qui l'opposé à bruno le maire
pour prendre les rênes de persil deux
centristes font leur arrivée une
surprise de poids david douillet
s'occupera du il peut en fait de les
troquer avec nous pour commenter cette
actualité benoît hamon bonjour avant
toute chose vous êtes porte parole du
parti socialiste vous allez commenter
avec nous ce rebondissement dans la
sphère dominique strauss kahn petit
rappel des faits le juge l'a
exceptionnellement exceptionnel convoqué
ce vendredi pour de nouveaux éléments
sur la plaignante en cause sont passés
de madame diallo oreilles de possibles
liens avec des activités criminelles
notamment un trafiquant de drogue il
aurait téléphoné à cet homme après
l'agression voilà pour les faits est ce
que cela change la donne
si j'espère que ça changera la donne
pour dominique strauss kahn
j'espère que les éléments réunis
par le procureur suffiront à confirmer
son innocence qu'il ne cesse de clamer
depuis le début c'est ce que nous nous
souhaitons depuis le début de cette
affaire et dans un temps qui celui là
justice américaine qui n'est pas
forcément celui des médias français qui
passerait forcément non plus celui de la
politique française mais qui nous livre
là en tout cas une rebondissements
potentiel qui est qui pourrait être
innocenté
dominique strauss kahn ce qui serait une
très bonne nouvelle pour lui une très
bonne nouvelle pour tous ceux qui en
sont proches
et pour le parti socialiste aussi ah bah
forcément forcément fait laver d'autres
non ça ça cette affaire avait sonné
comme un coup de tonnerre
très honnêtement et y avait laissé tout
le monde ne peut sidéré et puis c'est
tellement c'était tellement saisissant
est stupéfiant de voir ces images de
quelqu'un de menotter
alors qu'on venait de le quitter
quasiment puisqu'il revenait d'un
déplacement à paris c'était saison et en
même temps les fêtes et s'il était grave
les faits reprochés ne pouvait pas
s'empêcher de penser aussi à la
plaignante si c'était si les faits
étaient avérés donc c'est mettez tout le
monde dans une situation a quitté une
situation difficile mais surtout lui
donc surtout lui sur
voilà peut-être peut-être donc pour
l'instant les accusations as tu vois là
je reste prudent et que dans ce domaine
là je veux dire il ya encore quelques
semaines on nous reprochait de ne pas
avoir anticipé dans les rangs du parti
socialiste sur le fait qu'à un potentiel
criminel sexuel est présent de la
république sont comme des journalistes
qui nous ont dit ça sur les mêmes
aujourd'hui qui nous donne de dire tout
de suite si oui ou non il peut être
candidat aux présidentielles mais je
vais juste dire puisque cet emballement
initial on ne reprennent pas là et que
les procureurs d'hier se transforme pas
sûrs lendemain en oies blanches et qui
pour oublier ce qu'ils ont dit et qu'on
revienne juste à la prudence la raison
est la raison et la prudence
c'est bête attendre que la justice parle
que dominique strauss kahn par les
craintes
moi j'avais dit très précisément les
faits dicteront notre conduite et
dicteront la conduite de dominique
strauss kahn
voilà je les dis tout haut tout le temps
on va dire ce qui était le moment un peu
fort de la faire au départ je le redis
ça maintenant les faits nous dicteront
notre conduite est évidemment celle de
dominique strauss kahn aussi est ce que
le parti socialiste vous même vous vivez
au rythme des rebondissements de
dominique strauss kahn et de ces
affaires qui entourent dominique strauss
kahn est un peu bringuebalé finalement
et la vip ça eu des conséquences sur la
vie politique française juste vous
rappeler que si madame lagarde est
aujourd'hui directrice générale du fmi
dieu place dominique strauss kahn c'est
parce que dominique strauss-kahn a dû
quitter ses fonctions
je me souviens aussi une création je
crois du premier ministre disant que la
morale avait changé de camp
je suis mes souvenirs sont bons il ya de
mieux réguler quoi je les dis la même
chose que ce que j'ai dit heures c'est
que nous attendons nous que les faits
soient avérés ou pas et qu'ils disent
leur vérité et donc à partir de là mais
raisonnablement je viens six heures à
leur raisonnablement avec raison nous
agirons on se souvient aussi qu un point
presse du parti socialiste donc vous
êtes évidemment le poids de paroles que
vous animez on avait dit c'était une
affaire personnelle qui concerne les
dominique strauss-kahn et qu'il ne
concernait pas le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est avec les nouveaux
robots de son conte connaît elle
concerne surtout et aussi le mag il
ajouté et comme quoi il faut je les ai
stinat sphère privée effectivement
qu'ici pas une affaire qui concerne le
parti socialiste n'est que ça concernait
l'un des siens c'est que du moment où
l'un des nôtres et est en cause on
pouvait pas et je me serais il aurait
été particulièrement malhonnête d'être
dans le déni et dire bah non écoutez on
n'est pas impacté bien sûr qu'on a été
collectivement impactés par cette
nouvelle là en même temps j'observe que
les français ont de suite fait la
différence
on nous avait dit à écouter avec cette
affaire le parti socialiste va plonger
dans les sondages dans les intentions de
vote et françois hollande et martine
aubry vont plonger îlots réalité ils ont
trouvé des soutiens qu'ils aient des
soutiens qui montrent que les français
font la différence entre ce qui relevait
d'une affaire privée et de leurs
problèmes politiques de tous les jours
un bon ramadan quelle minute quelques
menues quelles conséquences aux
rebondissements peut avoir sur les
primaires du parti socialiste
mais d'abord peux-tu retour en arrière
mardi martine aubry fait son entrée en
scène
martine aubry candidate à l'élection
présidentielle une annonce faite dans la
ville de lille dont elle est la mère
loin de paris et du siège du parti
socialiste dont les ténors n'ont pas été
invités pour l'occasion martine aubry
qui a pris l'engagement du rassemblement
et de la victoire pour 2012 écoutez j'ai
décidé de proposer ma candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
avec votre soutien avec votre confiance
je prends aujourd'hui devant vous
l'engagement de la victoire en 2012
benoît hamon michèle sabban qui est une
des responsables du parti socialiste a
dit qu'il fallait éventuellement annuler
les primaires ou en tout cas les
retarder vous êtes d'accord avec elle
vous vous seriez qu'on va les regarder
elle est très proche
dominique strauss kahn elle il faut pas
aller plus vite que la musique c'est à
dire que nous sommes tous des dirigeants
responsable je crois que le parti
socialiste a montré très grand niveau de
responsabilité dans toute cette affaire
il le montrera dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent
commençons pas à faire c'est trop tôt
mais éventuellement on peut y penser a
annulé ses ou retarder cette fois ce
n'est pas de l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
voilà je ne sais même pas si les charges
sont abandonnées
quand je ne peux pas on ne peut pas
avoir une offre aux à 7h du matin et à
10h qu'on nous demande si tout le
calendrier politique est remis en cause
on a juste besoin de regarder si oui ou
non ce qui ce qui relève du commentaire
pour l'instant va être confirmé par la
justice américaine et si c'est confirmé
on se parle on discute on regarde on
attend l'avis des principaux concernés
voilà mais on fait la politique fiction
s'il échoue à ce jour si oui si on peut
imaginer un retour de mai s'il est
innocenté il fera ensuite les choix
qu'il voudra mais laissons-lui
s'exprimer comment vous je peux pas me
mettre à sa place vous il est dans une
situation d'une situation où il est
passé du zénith des sondages
du zénith de là on va dire des
responsabilités au niveau international
à la prison de rikers island et aux
menottes autour des poignets à une
résidence surveillée tout aussi agréable
soit elle mais une privation de liberté
et un procès pour des accusations
extrêmement graves puisqu'il s'agirait
d'une agression sexuelle et d'un viol
donc tout lui une trajectoire comme
celle là ça peut vous endurcir mais ça
peut aussi je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
pensent donc je peux vous dire à quoi ça
servirait chacun sont la conviction si
on mais voilà alors où en pointe où tout
s'échange et ne sait bien que à la télé
maintenant c'est la mode des des toc et
c'est à des discussions de café mais bon
honnêtement moi la team conviction de
benoît hamon la vôtre la soie doute un
intérêt profond pour les dix n'ont
jamais trop vite mais non mais c'est le
messie qu'on sait rien et qu'on va
parler pour rien dire donc ce sera rien
de parler pour rien dire elle apparaît
l'ont peut-être se demande si le
brillant des dépêches afp pour rien dire
mais bon on peut parler de martine aubry
ça c'est un personnes concrètes qui a
fait une annonce concrète
ce mardi c'est une candidature de devoir
selon vous de voir si 6/10 de voir ça
voudra dire je compte que dès le débat
c'est qu'elle n'a pas envie et patati et
patata
je connais guère de personnes qu'ils
aillent à l'élection présidentielle sont
d'avoir envie d'être président de la
république un mets haut puisque c'était
pas triste mais le devoir c'est surtout
de d'en finir avec le sarkozysme et
finir avec la gesticulation finir avec
l'agitation en finir avec l'inconstance
en finir avec le service la priorité aux
intérêts particuliers
en disant cela le pire est que je ne
suis même pas caricatural
c'est que c'est hélas la réalité perçue
par les français voilà donc
et ça suppose un projet et beaucoup de
constance et de cohérence et je crois
qu'elle qu'elle l'a cette constance
cette cohérence ne peut pas dire que les
autres candidats aux primaires non non
pas qu'elle là pour elle que ce soit
immédiatement perceptible dans ses choix
ses paroles vous êtes ça n'est pas un
secret un soutien de martine aubry en
soutien fervent il y a des ralliements
cette semaine qui se sont fait vers
françois hollande notamment gérard
collomb ou pierre moscovici sont des
ralliements qui vous inquiète ce sont
des poids lourds quand même oui mais oui
ce sont des poids lourds mais ça
dépendra autant par un jour mais pas
moyen non mais je veux dire s'il ya des
poids lourds par tous si c'est pas un
congrès du parti socialiste ce qui
importera c'est de convaincre les
français c'est le français qui vote ne
sont pas les militants socialistes de la
section 2 du 4e arrondissement de lyon
où vous de montbéliard ou même de
trappes où je suis aussi kaka ou des
ralliements mais sa grande assemblée un
congrès n'ont finalement mais parce
qu'il faut bien que les uns et les
autres s'exprimer disent leurs
préférences et disent pourquoi
quel type de projet ils défendent
quel type d'ambition ils ont au terme de
rénovation la démocratie je pense
évidemment à la question du cumul des
mandats je pense qu'elle lit d une zone
la transition écologique oui ou non
s'engage tout ce que moi je souhaite
vers une réduction de la dépendance du
nucléaire mais avec des choix politiques
des choix industriels des
investissements qu'ils soient consentis
pour qu'on ait un modèle énergétique
beaucoup plus sobre est-ce qu'on est dû
est ce que au lendemain notre élection
la priorité ce sera de savoir comment on
plaît aux agences de notation ou comment
on répond aux problèmes des français
ces questions me sont posées par les
français vous savez moi un coteau que je
travaille on me demande mais attendez
est ce que c'est bien sérieux d'annoncer
que vous voulez une politique fait une
politique de soutien du pouvoir au
pouvoir d'achat vous allez avoir les
marchés financiers qui vont nous dire
non et à ce moment là si notre politique
est fait en fonction des marchés
financiers autant rendre les clés de la
démocratie tout simplement pourquoi
pourquoi faudrait-il consulter les
français les français vont pas nous
demander de faire plaisir aux agences de
notation ils vont nous dire moi j'ai un
problème de loyer j'ai un problème de
revenus disponibles et du carnet six ans
c'est parce qu'ici nous assurer que les
gens qui vont venir
ça va même bien au-delà de ce que nous
voyons une dernière question donné mon
ladesou français pour venir voter vous
même jean françois copé vous restez
porte parole c'est confirmé
alors fonction l'a jamais été
sérieusement envisagée que je ne le sois
pas ségolène royal porte un peu la même
option difficilement compatibles un
porte parole
quelques le soutient martine aubry non
mais c'est encore une parole qui ensuite
il ya une réunion où les personnes
concernées ségolène royal martine aubry
les autres dirigeants socialistes d'un
côté les politiques se sont retrouvés
pendus qua non exécution ne se pose est
pas un mais pourquoi parce qu'on peut
être il manquerait plus que ceux qui
sont engagés dans le fait de défendre le
parti socialiste ces propositions mais
pas d'avis sur les prêts verts
moi j'ai exprimé un avis ça veut pas
dire pour autant que je dénigre qui que
ce soit d'autre
et j'ai pu exprimer un avis qui serait
curieux c'est que la seule personne qui
ait pas d'avis ce soit le porte-parole
du parti socialiste harlem désir il a un
avis aussi viennent prendre
la terrine il va assurer le
fonctionnement mis là aussi un ami tout
le monde connaît on a tous un avis il
manquerait plus courte vous ne serez pas
un porte-parole neutre je suis dans ma
fonction porte parole je défends le
projet socialiste mais quand alors je
vais vous prendre les élections
présidentielles ça n'ait pas demandé au
présent la république sortant de
démissionner parce qu'il n'est pas
neutre dans la gestion de l'état
vous lui demanderez à démissionner le
premier ministre devra démissionner
pendant la campagne du président de la
république s'il se représente non mais
c'est une curiosité la neutralité ça
voudra dire que je n'ai plus d'avis ça
fait trois ans que j'ai pris en charge
alors que ce n'était pas à la mode à
l'époque l'opposition à nicolas sarkozy
que j'ai débattu et tous les ministres à
un moment où certains en étaient presque
à complimenter parfois un certain nombre
d'initiatives du gouvernement est
maintenant à la fin au moment où il faut
en découdre
j'aurais pas d'avis bonjour est ce
qu'elles sont dans la vie parce que ça
fait j'ai un petit peu d'expérience même
nom de ce qu'est l'opposition à nicolas
sarkozy pour savoir à mon avis quel peut
être le bon choix ou la bonne formule
pour le battre voilà on va passer du
côté de l'ump justement le week-end
dernier à l'ump avait concentré ses tirs
sur le candidat hollande françois fillon
notamment avait brocardé la présidence
normale incompatible avec la fonction
est bien la candidature aubry a
également inspiré les députés de la
majorité extrait pour l'instant sa
campagne pour l'instant son comportement
dans l'impression que c'est une
candidate qui va par défaut depuis la
défection de dsk et c'est vraiment le
sentiment que j'ai c'est à dire qu'elle
se prononce au dernier moment
on sent qu'elle n'a pas envie je pense
que dans la campagne présidentielle ça
risque d'être très préjudiciable si
jamais elle passe de le cap des
primaires au soleil c'est une femme qui
sait ce qu'il veut qui est bien calé sur
ses pattes
cela étant c'est une adversaire
politique car elle a fait un certain
nombre de conneries et bien demandé aux
français sur les 35 heures c'est ça leur
a rapporté beaucoup
un petit résumé des attaques qui aura
cependant cette cette campagne mais je
préfère ce que 10 milliards presque 10
tardive parce que meilleur et il avoir
sur le fond on met il la convainc sur le
fond et les uns des 35 heures il est
contre les 35 heures les zapa remet en
cause puisque ils ont un autre avion
part met en cause la durée légale
ils ont fait la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires dont j'avais eu
le courage d'aller au bout de leurs
convictions
non moi il sait plus intéressant que ce
petit numéro des faits pas partir des
éléments de sa brillante quand même de
la campagne l'elysée sur wii et c'est
une candidate par défaut et plein de la
plante dans la vie et dogmatique
finalement assez les deux mots qui
reviendront de mathijsen 35 ferrand ça
s'appelle l'air du temps et l'air du
temps c'est la petite musique siffloter
par l'elysée et qu'on ne verra dès
l'heure du temps c'est le destin des
feuilles mortes un rêve et il pense que
je pense nicolas sarkozy à force d'être
dans l'air du temps aura lui aussi le
destin des feuilles mortes il ya cette
campagne d'affichés et de tracts de
l'ump primaire ps égale fichage
politique
c'est une mesure
cette source d'aliments paris manoir
c'est le style de la droite actuelle
compte que d'une partie de ceux qui
dirigent la droite actuelle je pense pas
que tous les dirigeants de l'ump soit
sur ce créneau là mais en tout cas c'est
le ton voulu par françois fillon nicolas
sarkozy et copé c'est à dire un truc ton
très agressif mais qui vous l'apprendrez
leur intérêt je ne reviens pas du tac au
tac
si on répondra quand on se trouvera ça
on a répondu sur le sûr parler par les
règles on a répondu par le fait que la
cnil nous avait donné son accord que le
ministre de l'intérieur avait dit que
nous nos primaires étaient légales donc
on répond en même temps c'est parfois
très violentes si le fichage ça renvoie
quand même des choses très précises et
c'est par un joli moon après est donc
bon bah écoutez on fait avec la droite
qu'on a mais le problème c'est que les
français aussi font avec cette droite là
et et que dans leur vie ça se traduit
par davantage aujourd'hui de difficultés
à l'est mardi toujours nicolas sarkozy
organise un joli coup médiatique alors
que le ps peaufine son affrontement des
primaires le président part en visite
pour la première fois sur les terres de
son premier ministre dans la sarthe
quatre ans qu'ils se partagent la tête
de l'exécutif jamais il ne s'était
autant apprécié l'amour dans le pré un
sujet d'anaïs ou bastien battre la
campagne pour occuper le terrain et pas
n'importe quelle campagne nicolas
sarkozy a choisi la terre de son premier
ministre la sarthe fief de françois
fillon jamais encore visitées par le
président depuis 2007 les deux hommes
arrivent ensemble en hélicoptère visite
une entreprise florissante de la région
objectif montrer que le couple exécutif
et plus soudés que jamais à moins d'un
an de la présidentielle
j'ai l'honneur depuis quatre ans de
conduire le gouvernement de la france
sous votre autorité
j'essaye de le faire du mieux que je le
peux j'essaie de ne pas vous décevoir
on en a affronté des difficultés mais ce
fut toujours pour moi un grand soutien
que de pouvoir compter sur le conseil et
sur le sens de l'état de françois fillon
après les compliments nicolas sarkozy
passe au sujet du jour la sécurité
alimentaire sa façon à lui de commenter
les primaires socialistes
tellement de choses importantes dans
l'actualité mais moi je pense qu'au
contraire nous sommes avec françois
fillon dans la vraie actualité des
français peuvent-ils avoir confiance
dans ce qu'ils achètent pour se nourrir
la vraie actualité des français entendez
loin des préoccupations internes du
parti socialiste le jour du coup d'envoi
des primaires nicolas sarkozy a voulu
lui aussi capté sa part de lumière en
montrant l'image d'un tandem exécutif
stable au travail sur le terrain et au
contact des français benoît hamon
faisait saisi le message à l'ump on
s'entend bien on travaille on parle des
vraies préoccupations des français
pas comme ailleurs choque tout le monde
vous on est je suis baba et ne profite
qu il a changé il est plus cool c'est ça
non mais c'est ce qu'on nous dit mauges
orageux gens je ne suis qu'un simple
spectateur de ce qu'est la communication
élyséenne où nous dit qu'il est plus
serein plus cool donc écoutez moi je
suis très heureux qu'on soit dirigée au
bout de quatre ans et demi quatre ans
par un président plus cool dans mon côté
lui la semaine mardi toujours elle
espérait être nommé ce jour pour faire
un peu d'ombré à martine aubry c'est
chose faite christine lagarde remplace
dominique strauss kahn à la tête du fmi
fier de son bilan 2008 l'économie elle
passe au rang de chef d'état et ne
cachait pas son émotion au moment de son
annonce devant l'assemblée nationale
écoutez je voudrais tout simplement
partager avec tous nos concitoyens avec
les français la fierté qui est la mienne
la fierté de toutes les femmes aussi à
travers moi de prendre une fonction
importante et je voudrais simplement
vous dire qu'ici pour moi bat le coeur
de la république et que le mien bat pour
vous benoît hamon christine lagarde à la
tête du fmi c'est un moment d'unité
nationale une victoire diplomatique qui
nous française puisse reprendre la place
d'un français non non c'est pas lui
c'est pas le sujet honnêtement on peut
la trouver parfaitement respectable et
moi j'ai
chaque fois que j'ai débattu avec même
lagarde trouver une femme de conviction
respectable donc c'est pas caractère qui
est en cause ses qualités je n'oublie
pas qui est une procédure devant la cour
de justice de la république nom et avec
un réquisitoire du national qui était
particulièrement clair pour rappeler que
à plusieurs moments de la procédure dans
l' affaire tapie jugé qu'il y avait une
commandite volonté madame la garde de
deux peut-être de favoriser ce tapis
donc cette procédure demeure elle n'est
pas totalement éteinte à 10 années ben
voila mais est ensuite après il ya les
convictions de madame lagarde
ouais je peux on peut reconnaître les
qualités d'une femme est en même temps
et au total désaccord avec la stratégie
qui a été la sienne qui a consisté au
bout du compte à croire et à continuer à
croire que les marchés financiers peut
représenter une forme d'optimum en
matière de l'allocation du capital et
est donc un optimum économique et qu'il
fallait laisser fonctionner le mieux
possible sans entraves etc etc bref
c'est une libérale or aujourd'hui nous
avons besoin de régulation et je ne
crois pas qu'elle soit donc quel est le
profil politique adéquate pour diriger
le fmi
en même temps je vais vous dire pas non
plus faire une
trop grosse affaire de tout cela si vous
vous demandez quel était le nom du
patron du fmi avant dominique strauss
kahn pas grand monde qui sans
rappellerait pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a
qu'en france qu'on pense que désormais
c'est une sorte de chef d'état que
d'être le patron du fmi c'est le
directeur général nils où il travaille
avec les représentants des élus ont eu
la crise en même temps et c'est là où on
a vu l'action durant force puis on dit
d'accord il ya un renforcement du rôle
du fmi les notations qui est beaucoup
plus importante cela étant dit le
directeur général du fmi tout aussi
talentueux soit-il il travaille sous
l'autorité des représentants des états
et ce sont les états qui décident et en
l'occurrence l'état qui dispose de la
minorité de blocage au conseil
d'administration du fonds monétaire
international je rappelle le seul ce
sont les états unis d'amérique et c'est
donc le trésor américain qui a une
influence considérable sur les choix du
fonds monétaire international cet
historique vous ne dites par là que le
bilan 2009 transcanada du fmi n'est pas
sinon je me voyais plus comme comme vous
êtes je vous dis pas ça je vous dis
juste qu'il faut toujours relativiser et
dominique strauss kahn le faisait lui
même
c'est pour ça que je le fais assez
sereinement faut relativiser ce qu est
la place et le rôle
du directeur général du fmi il ne peut
pas endosser heureusement pour lui
d'ailleurs
là est toute la responsabilité les choix
qui sont faits il ya une doctrine aurait
famille qui précédait bien cédé presque
est très ancienne notamment en termes de
politiques d'ajustement structurel de
conditionnement des prêts il ya ensuite
conseil d'administration d état qui pèse
dans ces conseils d'administration et
qui détermine les grands choix
politiques amis de la terre général il
est là pour mettre en musique organisée
les négociations il a un rôle important
strauss kahn avait par exemple favoriser
la voix des pays émergents en cancer
sont des acquis sur lesquels christine
lagarde doit revenir emprunter
normalement des charges d'abord il faut
savoir que le poids dans le conseil
ministration du formateur international
et de lio pour votre poids économique
c'est one dollar one voice en clair en
gros plus vous êtes lourd économiquement
plus vous peser
donc il ya une révision régulièrement se
rappelle les quotes parts et des droits
de vote au sein du conseil
d'administration du fonds monétaire
international qui est aussi le résultat
de la montée en puissance des économies
comme la chine le brésil ou l'inde donc
c'est de toute façon une voix
indispensable et une voie qu'il a tracée
il a eu raison de le faire après
après ce que seront les orientations
données par madame lagarde je ne sais
pas mais comment vous dire moi je suis
premier vous pour elle si elle elle doit
attendait d'eux très heureuse
après pour les français pour les
européens pour les pays qui sont inclus
dans le plan câble
ses premiers mots ont été rouverts la
grèce qui connaît également y rendre
arrive pour envers les marchés grecs ou
envers les
citoyens grecs la question bas voilà
j'attends de voir ce qu'il en sera je
pense que tout cas en europe ont fait de
la pire des politiques qu'ils soient
c'est-à-dire l'austérité partout en même
temps
or le problème des européens c'est que
l'essentiel des autres on va pas rentrer
dans ce débat maintenant mais on a le
choix
bien sûr qu'on a le choix c'est ça qui
est même tragique pourquoi est ce que
les gens votent plus c'est qu'on
n'arrête pas de le répéter qu'on n'a pas
le choix c'est qu'en économie n'y aura
plus qu'une seule politique économique
possible sais pas d'où ça tombe si on
sait bien qu'il ya un terreau à cela
mais c'est pas possible c'est pas comme
n'était pas possible de continuer à dire
que pour la retraite il n'y a qu'une
seule voie possible qui est qu'on
travaille plus non il ya plusieurs voies
possibles question de savoir qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on alloue comme moyen
chaque politique
aujourd'hui il ya clairement un débat
budgétaire devant nous un débat sur la
dette devant nous un débat sur les
stratégies économiques devant nous il
aura lieu d'ailleurs pendant les
primaires mais il y aura lieu sur tout
pendant l'élection présentielle aller
mercredi puisque christine lagarde s'en
va remaniement obligatoire au
gouvernement il faut donc trouver un
remplacement peau christine lagarde à
bercy c'est l'heure du remaniement
on pensait la chose entendue mais ce
remaniement a tourné à la lutte entre
les quadras du gouvernement entre petit
chantage petites trahisons entre amis le
feuilleton a duré toute la journée et
finalement le duel a tourné en faire
françois barois les explications tout de
suite dans ce sujet le grand gagnant
c'est lui après une bataille acharnée
françois baroin obtient ce qu'il voulait
il remplace christine lagarde à bercy
devient ministre de l'économie et des
finances et quitte son poste de
porte-parole du gouvernement
une belle promotion pour cet ancien
chiraquien qui ce matin déjà avant
l'annoncé officielle affichait un large
sourire plein de sous-entendus
ce matin bruno le maire lui quitte
rapidement la cour de l'elysée après le
conseil des ministres
bercy le ministre de l'agriculture y
être jusqu'au bout hier il faisait
partie du déplacement de nicolas sarkozy
et de françois fillon dans la sarthe et
semblait tenir la corde mais françois
baroin n'a pas dit son dernier mot et
met sa démission dans la balance c'est
bercy
or rien mais viser matignon tranche ce
sera à bercy
cette nomination sonne le glas d'une
amitié entre les deux hommes qui
jusqu'ici affiché leur complicité déçu
bruno le maire refuse le budget égard de
son poste à l'agriculture c'est valérie
pécresse qui remplacera françois baroin
au ministère du budget et au porte
parolat
celle qui a mené la réforme de
l'université cède sa place à laurent
wauquiez qui devient donc ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur benoît hamon ça
vous inspire cette guerre des quadras
l'ump ça peut arriver aussi l'égard des
quadras pour parti socialiste recevra
mieux de ce côté là mais
comme animaux peta qui exaspère vote est
un peu plus long mais moi j'ai rien
contre les individus les connais pas
bien en même temps mais me paraissent
eux je connais pas bien françois baehr
mois le maire non plus
je suis maintenant ça va pas changer
grand chose donc
bon voilà qui est des ambitions que ça
se chamaille à droite va pas faire ce
moment de découvrir que bertrand dts
copé et qui déteste bertrand qu'il était
seulement bref mais ça c'est la vie dans
je suis me sens pas bien placé pour
faire la leçon parce qu'au ps qu'on n'a
pas non plus toujours été dans le passé
exemplaire
ça va mieux mais comme on n'est jamais
impossible qu'il ait rechute donc voilà
donc l'essentiel c'est de savoir à quoi
ça a servi ce remaniement on a compris
alors du coup david douillet inaugura
oui on va le dire à la d'état aux
français de l'étranger
alors ça ça vous aspect un peu plus
peut-être ça m'inspire je comprenais
qu'il ya une réforme des institutions
qui veut qu'à neuf circonscriptions
désormais neuf députés qui a des
électeurs qui a coûté près d'un million
de voix au jeu pour le noyau journal
bien que david douillet a expliqué aux
binationaux
ce qu'étaient les projets ou ce que sont
les projets l'ump qui veulent interdire
la binationalité ou en tout cas le
restreindre considérablement parce que
pour l'essentiel beaucoup des français
pas pour l'essentiel mais beaucoup de
français et d'étrangers sont des
binationaux et sont attachés à cette au
fait d'avoir la double nationalité donc
on voit bien que dans ce cas était
l'obsession
identitaire de ceux de la droite qui
continue à courir après madame le pen on
a pu on pourrait remettre en cause le
principe de la binationalité donc
peut-être que la vie nettoyer ira
éclairer les choix du gouvernement notre
cas sur ce sujet il va avoir quelques
difficultés à convaincre nos
compatriotes présents à l'étranger
ce sera une sorte de tournée de
séduction qui va devoir faire dans l'est
dans les mois qui viennent crois que
c'est un peu l'objectif du président de
la république mais tu vas nous expliquer
qu'ils occupent s'intéresse à la
sécurité alimentaire qui n'est pas du
tout intéressé par les primaires alors
qu'il a passé outre vouloir a expliqué
par le biais de scopeo guéant que tout
ça c'était du fichage qui ne s'intéresse
pas du tout à travers ce remaniement et
en faisant des prises chez les
centristes aux élections locales en les
lisant votre emploi on ne peut pas lui
reprocher d'être d'être de s'intéresser
à sa propre réélection ce qui est
fatigant c'est qu'ils jouent les
hypocrites en disant qu'ils
s'intéressent à tout autre chose qu'à ça
d'où il a été élu on a compris que à la
fois nicolas sarkozy
prenez du plaisir à gouverner jouissait
du pouvoir au point de que ça se voit
beaucoup et qu'il avait envie d'en jouir
longtemps et
la question c'est est ce que les
français sont une fois maintenant une
fois qu'ils ont vu ce que ça donnait le
sarkozysme est ce qu'ils ont envie de
lui faire à nouveau ce plaisir o'gara je
ne crois pas je l'espère pas aller
mercredi toujours chacun apprend à sa
façon la libération des deux otages
français en afghanistan pour les députés
c'est bernard acoyer qui leur annonce la
nouvelle en pleine séance de questions
au gouvernement céline bittner il est
15h30 quand bernard accoyer prend
subitement la parole en pleine séance de
questions au gouvernement
les deux journalistes de france 3 hervé
ghesquière et stéphane taponier seraient
libérés
l'ovation durent plusieurs secondes
des applaudissements soutenus à droite
et à gauche des élus sont visiblement
ému sourions soulagé de cette nouvelle
bernard accoyer est le premier à évoquer
la libération d'hervé ghesquière et
stéphane taponier mais pas encore au
conditionnel
il faut attendre quelques minutes et le
communiqué officiel de l'elysée pour que
cette fois françois fillon interviennent
dans l'hémicycle je veux vous confirmer
que depuis quelques heures nos deux
otages français en afghanistan sont
entre les mains des forces françaises
sur la base de taggart nos deux otages
sont en bonne santé et ils seront dans
quelques heures sur le sol français dans
les couloirs de l'assemblée
l'intervention de françois fillon est
suivi de près par les journalistes mais
aussi par cet homme le député de marcq
en baroeul la ville d'hervé ghesquière
il tente de joindre la maman de l'ex
otage 84 on
femmes du caire a été étonnante moi j'ai
toujours était certain que que son fils
serait libérée et en bonne santé
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a une
force de caractère absolument étonnante
et je me suis dit si son fils et comme
la maman
il va s'en sortir je suis très très
heureux pour lui et très heureux pour
mon pays
ministres députés candidats à la
présidentielle tous manifestent très
rapidement leur joie après cette annonce
la libération des deux otages comme une
parenthèse politique qui à l'assemblée a
même éclipsé pour un temps le
remaniement ministériel dans cette
réjouissance collective l'assemblée qui
fait du bien à voir de temps en temps au
delà donc il ya eu des quelques noms pas
polémique mais quelques questions par un
foudre est il en savoir plus sur les
conditions de leur libération à votre
avis les rançons libération chef taliban
où on s'arrête là
écoutez on a d'autres otages qui sont
encore détenus projet au mali
écoutez moi j'attends du
gouvernement qu'il des services de
l'état et son âge il faut saluer tous
ceux qui ont permis cette libération
qu'il obtienne la libération de ce petit
reste je resterai jeu restera ce
commentaire à cette étape parce que
bruxelles je suis à la fois très heureux
pour stéphane taponier hervé ghesquière
c'était des images qui était très
émouvante
mais ils ont aussi rappelé que le rôle
des journalistes de faire leur travail
est d'aller chercher l'information au
sirop donc adresser à votre vie non je
pense pas que la polémique ils l'ont dit
pas qu'elle était malvenu mais je pense
que d'ailleurs ceux qui ont enclenché
cette polémique se taisent aujourd'hui
ils auraient et
et donc je crois que lui aujourd'hui on
n'entend pas beaucoup sur ce point là
mais il a raison et puis et puis après
voilà je pense aux autres otages est
donc voilà c'est pas une tâche facile
salut nous met donc celle du desservi de
ceux du quai d'orsay spam de nos
services de renseignement
voilà il ya un travail qui est un
travail qui me paraît difficile de
commenter mais je n'en connais pas le
détail et qui a besoin d'être minimum 10
ans va passer au jeudi
on reparle des primaires mais pas les
vôtres en ce jeudi donc premier grand
débat deux derniers d'ailleurs d'entre
deux tours chez les écologistes face à
face il ne reste plus que deux dont eva
joly face à nicolas hulot
un débat qui a failli ne pas avoir lieu
car eva joly a manqué de peu la veille
la majorer la majorité absolue dès le
premier tour
49 7% des voix débat plus apaisé en ce
jeudi soir julie eu la difficile de
croire que les militants pourront y voir
plus clair ce soir bien loin des
précédentes rivalité nicolas hulot a
débuté le débat en le plaçant sous le
signe du rassemblement
je m'étais préparé pour combattre
beaucoup de choses mais très sincèrement
je me suis pas préparé j'ai pas du tout
envie de me battre de combattre eva joly
comme j'ai pas eu envie de combattre qui
que ce soit dans les candidats les
candidats
je voudrais dire combien l'unité
maintenant est importante
je pense qu'il ya eu un temps pour se
différencier pour permettre aux
militants de se déterminer
ce temps-là est passé dès lors le débat
très vite tourné à une mise en scène
commune de tous les grands combats
d'europe écologie sortie du nucléaire
réforme de la fiscalité innovation à
coups de hochements de tête et
d'applaudissements mutuelle
rien n'est venu les opposé sur le fond
lance attaques n'ont finalement été
menée que contre le gouvernement de
nicolas sarkozy
est ce que c'est la peine que l'état
subventionne d'assaut pour vendre des
rafale est ce que c'est la peine de
construire un nouvel aéroport aux portes
de nantes
est ce que c'est la peine de construire
un nouveau grand stade en banlieue
lyonnaise alors qu'il ya des instants
nous allons pas jouer au petit minimes
remaniement ministériel
je crois que nicolas sarkozy est à son
onzième remaniement et ça me donne une
image assez lamentable et nous n'allons
pas nous engager d'associer la unie et
rassemblée c'est le nous qui a donc
primé lors de ce débat
la seule différence l'opposition entre
ces deux personnages un nicolas hulot
toujours aussi détendu et combatifs face
à une eva joly plus en retrait est
accrochée à ses fiches
c'est pourtant elle qui a séduit les
militants écologistes et pris l'avantagé
pour l'instant le second tour débute ce
soir
résultat le 12 juillet c'est un score
qui vous a surpris
pour eva joly il n'avait pas été prévu
par les sondages à ce point mais parce
que tu as possible de sonder le vote de
30000 personnes dont vous savez pas
faire l'échantillon en open ont sont pas
les mêmes collèges électoraux donc quand
un sondage effet il est fait auprès de
l'opinion mais le pignon c'est pas les
militants verts ses palais les 30000
donc ça n'avait pas beaucoup de valeur
il veut dire que pour voix sondage à
vous c'est la même chose de très
différent ce qu'ils sont nous ce sont
tous les français qui sont appelés à
voter c'est comme si c'était la primeur
est six communes et louis mais comme à
une élection il ya le moyen que les
trois victoires alors qu'ils n'allaient
pas parfois 60 % du corps électoral qui
se déplacent pas il n'est donc c'est
très différente de ce qui s'est passé là
où c'était les adhérents des verts donc
par ailleurs la primaire est très
ouverte
la nôtre donc mais comparons pas ce qui
est pas comparable et sont descendus
tout vouloir un jour y est ce que la
qualité du processus s'initie par les
verts qui était un processus
démocratique mais réservé pour
l'essentiel à leurs adhérents et alors
très proche sympathisants là nous nous
disons on fait des bureaux de vote
quiconque a une carte électorale peut
venir
c'est quand même totalement différent
puisque c'est tout le collège électoral
français qui est appelé à voter aux
promeneurs aux primaires pour en revenir
europe ecologie les verts qu'est-ce qui
a travaillé explique que les militants
acceptent aussi peu cette candidature de
nicolas hulot on le sent dans l'armée
voyez je crois une forte campagne sur ce
qu'a été le la trajectoire précédente
nicolas hulot le fait qu'il était
animateur sur tf1 que ça a pesé sur son
son erreur aussi quand il a parlé des
centristes une alliance possible avec
jean louis borloo 7
cette ouverture possible sur le centre
qui était sans doute maladroite surtout
que les versions comme inscrits dans des
combats à gauche maintenant depuis de
nombreuses années après moi je jette pas
la pierre il intègre un jeu politique
est un jeu
dont les règles sont parfois quand même
dur et il faut le dire est pas moins dur
chez les écolos qu'elles le sont
ailleurs et donc vol à voile et
continuer le combat j'ai jamais devait
perdre les primaires se brûle espérer
oui j'espère c'est une moi je le
connaissais pas et jamais plus peut-être
même quelques a priori je vais vous dire
sur le
le bonhomme est ce que j'ai entendu ce
que j'ai vu ce que j'ai lu et
l'engagement qu'il a mis dans cette
campagne donne envie qu'il leur est un
acteur engagé et du combat l'écologie ce
qu'il restera
peu importe d'ailleurs ce que j'en pense
d'ailleurs j'imagine mais du combat de
la gauche même s'il perd 7 prévert voilà
je pense qu'il qu'il doit continuer
alors qu'il continue daniel cohn bendit
affirme dans une interview au journal
libération que le score de la
présidentielle d'europe écologie les
verts n'aura finalement aucune
importance bref il est très sceptique
encore une fois sur une candidature d'un
candidat pour l'élection présidentielle
venant d'europe écologie vous même vous
êtes pour une candidature verte ou pas
toujours est ce qu'il faut maintenir
cette candidature et coutumes moi je
pense que l'écologie politique
là une existence sans vos alliés on le
répète et indépendamment de nous et que
la vocation à exister y compris dans
l'élection présidentielle qui est quand
même la principale élections mécontent
on n'est pas content mais la principale
d'élections à la vie démocratique
française donc aujourd'hui je vois pas
beaucoup de raisons qui justifieraient
que cette parole là soit absente alors
je comprends la logique qui voudrait que
pour s'assurer que la gauche vote au
second tour
ça pourrait passer par une négociation
préalable entre les écologistes et les
socialistes sur nombre de
circonscriptions pour les législatives
un programme commun qui amènerait à une
candidature unique
je crois que c'est la logique défendue
par daniel cohn bendit en même temps ce
n'est pas celle défendue par la
direction des écologistes et je respecte
donc le point de vue de la direction des
écologistes
sa direction est animé par cécile duflot
qui a été confirmé dans son rôle avec un
très beau score lors de la demie congrès
elle est là la voie de l'écologie
politique et elle soutient comme je me
crois une très grande majorité des
sympathisants et de militants
écologistes le principe d'une
candidature en coin donc tout ce passe
mais avec vos alliés les verts baba
quand on discute qu'on a pas d'accord
sur tout sinon seraient offrait le même
parti d'ailleurs mais sinon donc on peut
avoir des discussions âpres parfois mais
ça se passe effectivement très bien et
moi je suis content de la qualité de
relation qu'on a c'est aussi parce qu'il
ya des changements de génération chez
eux que s'achève dans quelques années
changement de génération parti
socialiste et sur le monde génération
qui se manifeste aussi dans le contenu
des projets la proche que nous avons
quand génération à que j'ai des
questions liées à l'écologie en général
à la transition énergétique au choix de
politique industrielle qu'il faudra
faire
seront aussi marquées de ce saut de
génération qui existent dans toute autre
chose benoît avancé l'image de cette fin
de semaine que je vous propose de voir
tout de suite et bien c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui était en déplacement dans le
lot-et-garonne qui a été agrippé vous le
voyez sur ces images par le col par un
homme qui l'a violemment agressé benoît
hamon vous voyez ces images l'homme a
été interpellé dans la foulée placé en
garde à vue il sera jugé ce vendredi il
a déclaré qu'il avait en fait un
ras-le-bol général ou centre c'est la
première fois
finalement qu'un homme qu'un président
de la république est agressé à ce point
là vous savez qu'il ya quelque chose qui
a changé en france
d'abord si choquant que quelqu'un
frapper le président de la république
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
avec lui violence physique est
inacceptable il est inacceptable je
rappelle que c'est en présence de la
république avait été lui les teams
l'objet d'une tentative avortée
d'attentât avec un 6 au 14 juillet il
veut donc dire que les plus hauts
responsables politiques sont toujours
exposés à la violence
ce qui est certain c'est que la société
française est aujourd'hui donc plus
violente qu'elle ne l'était il ya
quelques années et il ya des
responsabilités économiques tout ça et
nous mais il ya aussi des
responsabilités sociales politiques et
voilà mais en même temps en disant cela
utile une évidence mais rien ne justifie
qu'on va frapper ainsi à présent de
marathon mythe ni qui que ce soit alors
pour une opinion ou pour une autre mais
pas le président de la république
l'occurrence et bombay sait bien que
heureusement qui sait que c'était pas
autre chose et qu'ils n'étaient pas
armés
le monsieur en question d'annoncer la
fin de cette émission merci d'y avoir
participé
nous on se retrouve michael la semaine
prochaine notre chagrin au revoir au
revoir